[Musique]
et Mélanie poket nous a rejoint pour
notre rendez-vous junior et cette
semaine on s'envole pour le Grand Nord
chez les inuites un voyage glacé dans
ces terr tout en haut du globe ou
presque le en fait le voyage on va le
faire grâce à un spectacle qui a lieu en
ce moment même au Théâtre national de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline ça s'appelle
inou et c'est une création de la
compagnie l'uni jambiste mais celui qui
le présentera le mieux c'est David
gouchard le metteur en scène
[Musique]
donc ça parle de l'homme et en fait
c'était l'idée de d'interroger ma propre
histoire euh jeune papa je décide
d'aller fouiller ma mon histoire et
d'aller penser à mon grand-père mon
grand grandpère était ternua donc il
partait de fécan il était marin pêcheur
et il allait jusqu'au Groenland et à
ternuve et donc il a rencontré les
inouïes donc David parle de son
grand-père vous aurez compris c'est une
histoire familiale qu'il a lui aussi
voulu vivre alors il est parti au
nunavic une région québécoise
francophone rencontré des inuites il
n'est pas parti seul il était accompagné
de plusieurs membres de la Compagnie
dont un beatboxeer losos c'est son nom
alors dans la pièce il fait
principalement les brutages le vent les
anivaux mais aussi le catajck il nous
explique ce que c'est et on écoutera un
extrait à la suite chez les inuites il y
a cette pratique du catajac qui se fait
par les femmes principalement que par
les femmes et qui est un un un jeu vocal
d'expiration d'inspiration et c'est des
techniques assez particulières
et et le jeu consiste en en en garder le
rythme
[Musique]
alors c'est un spectacle mais on a
parfois l'impression de voir un vrai
documentaire et ça presque un
documentaire c'est en fait la compagnie
Camille veut transmettre à tous cette
histoire cette civilisation qui
elle-même se transforme un peu comme la
nôtre les jeunes ne sont pas nés dans
des iglous ils parlent de moins en moins
leur dialecte et ils sont parfois
déconnectés de leur propre héritage mais
il nous c'est avant tout un voyage
onirique et poétique une heure de
sensation d'être là-bas aussi dans un
univers qu'on ne connaît pas tout il est
les doudoun la glace les pingouins et le
bruit des pas sur la glace alors il y a
peu de paroles ça permet d'être
compréhensible à tout pardon à tous et
c'est surtout très visuel Ilous c'est à
découvrir jusqu'au 28 janvier donc même
pour les tout petits les plus petit
merci beaucoup Mélanie poquet de nous
avoir présenté ce spectacle on le
rappelle à découvrir au théâtre de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline